devant une hardy view vous avez bougé
j'ai bouché
on peut rallumer serge ce n'est pas
parce qu'il est ministre
oui vous allez avoir une hardy view en
bouche pendant le king
bien quand vous regarder dans la glace
le matin vous dites quoi ça dépend
franchement des jours joue finalement je
suis pas mécontent et d'autres où je dis
que le temps commence à passer
vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui quand
vous étiez petit clark des bols
peut-être ou stranger cole et senso et
senso mais aussi les contrebandiers de
moonfleet car à mouches c'est à dire
votre plus belle histoire d'amour c'est
vous
oui pierre est ce que vous seriez prêt à
tout quitter pour le grand amour
oui ah ouais sans problème non mais
sérieux ça le soit par thiriez au bout
du monde jusqu'à saint germain des prés
mais je ne serai pas changé le devance
désormais oui j'avais que vous avez
quitté les bains pour le floor j'habite
là j'habite là depuis longtemps mais de
quand je dis tous quitté s'est élevé des
poneys en argentine le grand amour ne
signifie pas forcément quand on fait des
trucs rasant ouais mais de changer pas
mal de choses dans sa vie bête lors
seriez prêt par exemple l'apport d'un
salon de coiffure pas moi je suis pas un
grand manuel mais oui intellectuellement
je conseille à la grèce quand avez vous
pleuré pour la dernière fois je crois
que c'est en voyant un film de comencini
qui s'appelle l'a compris un est mort
d'un enfant que son père n'a pas compris
justement et peut pas s'empêcher de
pleurer là je pleure assez souvent au
cinéma vous changeriez quoi en vous si
vous aviez une baguette magique
bon ben on le sait 5 kg - ouais
et puis pierre les cheveux longs et
bouclés vous savez que les femmes
préfèrent les choses ah bon regardez la
mode et ses footballeurs c'est vrai
barthez tout savoir thèse tous alors
faites vous raser complètement ça
viendra avec un anneau dans l'oreille
alors c'est plus compliqué que dragon
sur la joue quel est le péché qui vous
tente le plus celui que je pratique le
mois c'est le calme plat luxure
pratiquer palais luxueux
non que pourriez-vous dire depuis
négatif sur vous trop timide voilà ça va
oui mais je me force pas pourquoi c'est
comme ça c'est comme ça même
profondément choquant il vrai ça si vous
êtes premier ministre présentera public
va falloir vous lâche un peu il y en a
une autre
si votre vie il était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous changeriez je crois
que je recommencerai pareil pas parce
que
je trouve que les choses sont parfaites
mais parce que je suis sans être
optimiste ouais je suis quelqu'un qui
regarde toujours devant
ouais ouais je pense qu'on peut toujours
avancer mais dans votre bouquin c'est ça
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
j'ai plus l'avenir de l'europe mais
j'évite d'en confectionner pas j'ai pas
de nostalgie je ne pleure pas sur le
l'inversé vous fait pas partie de ces
juifs qui sont dans une espèce de
religion de la shoah toute la journée
pas du tout mais c'est quelque chose à
quoi je pense
j'ai été avec lunettes j'ose pas visité
auschwitz et ses souvenirs elle le
restera toujours
c'est quelque chose qui continue un
intérêt que je ne peux pas comprendre
mais j'ai pas du tout la religion de sa
reine mais je suis seul mais j'ai vu
aussi qu'il y avait maintenant des juifs
qui commence à expliquer qu'il ne
fallait pas voir là dedans c'est pour ça
que je pose la question restait des
choses dérisoires
je trouve honnêtement que cette démarche
là encore et entre le débile scandaleux
est-ce que là on touche à l'indicible
intouchable je crois que c'est c'est un
c'est quelque chose qui encore une fois
nous devons tous garder en mémoire
oui et des juifs qu'ils disent que cette
sacralisation de la shoah réduit
finalement la pensée juive
c'est pas la pensée c'est d'ailleurs pas
quelque chose qui me concerne uniquement
les juifs la shoah c'est quelque chose
qui nous concerne tous parce que c'est
l'une l'inhumain j'ai descendu sur la
terre et qui a été mise en oeuvre par
des hommes qui en plus étaient plutôt
des bureaucrates que des bourreaux parce
que tout a été pensé exécuté exactement
comme on administre il ya des choses
très simples en soins et des livres
écrits par des juifs qui disent que
finalement israël utilise la shoah pour
améliorer son image et finalement la
préserver des critiques qui pourraient
lui être faites sur la façon de traiter
les palestiniens oui on pensait qu est
ce qu on appelle une nouvelle histoire
où les vosges une alice non je suis pas
du tout sur cette ligne a dont je pense
que c'est pas vrai je pense pas que qui
israël utilise des choix et je pense que
encore une fois c'est pas un phénomène
qu'on peut banaliser
si on cherche à bâtir des choses comme
ça au final on finit par expliquer qu'il
ne faut plus en parler là il faut en
parler car elle insulte qui vous a fait
le plus de mal en pis il sait rien mais
c'est j'aime pas qu'on prenne pas un
idiot 1 vous n'avez pas de chance que
raison
justement c'est pour ça que ça me fait
mal qui avez-vous le plus envie d'épater
mon père peut-être vous abonner à télé 7
jours de quelles questions m e riez vous
avoir la réponse du existe-t-il
ouais je n'ai pas rencontré ouais j'y
croyais pas non vous pensez que c'est
l'homme qui a inventé dieu plutôt oui
plutôt que l' inverse plutôt que
l'averse